[Music]
Patriots day so Petry stays directed by
Peter Berg it's the biopic about the
Boston Marathon bombing and the manhunt
for the douchebags you did it stars Mark
Wahlberg is one of the Boston PD guys
amidst this crisis Kevin Bacon's the Fed
who comes in when the like this might be
terrorism it means it's our ballgame now
and now we have a pretty emotional right
here Peter Berg it looks like he has
found his niche and you like a Deepwater
Horizon Patriots days like his Peter
Berg just gonna keep doing movies about
tragedies that happened not too long ago
if so define go for a given the product
if this is what he is pumping out and
giving us I say don't stop he's given us
some pretty good stuff from that
spectrum and Mark Wahlberg was great in
this movie I thought he was great in
deepwater horizon also there's some
Oscar chatter about deepwater horizon I
think if he's gonna get nominated for
one of these two films Patriots day is
the one it would be and he was great in
both but there's just one scene in
particular in Patriots day we were
watching and you're like if he gets
nominated for an Oscar that's the clip
they're probably going to show where
they should show does that mean he's
gonna get nominated I have no idea I'm
so detached from the Oscar mindset I'm
the worst person to ask that question to
and quite frankly it doesn't matter in
the least to me point is he gave a great
performance in a great movie here Oscar
or not and it really is a compelling
thing I remember the Boston Marathon
bombing when it happened through the
manhunt - when it ended it was a pretty
intense thing and what this movie does
which is also what I noticed in Patton
Oswalt I think Facebook posted about
this Facebook or Twitter since it's more
than 140 characters I believe it was
Facebook and what you see a tragedy like
this and attack from people on people
you're like oh I've lost faith in
humanity but it's important to see the
people the normal people the common
folks there who were rushing to help the
injured people this movie does show that
spectrum of it as shitty people are
vastly outnumbered by the good people so
I'm glad this movie Illustrated that
point also this movie is great at
getting you to an emotional level and
just holding you there never really
breaks you are you never break down and
sob I held it in I probably would have
had I let myself but it gets you to that
welling you know you get the knot in the
throat and your eyes are welling up and
it just it holds you there for a very
long time because it's a very emotional
thing I just don't like seeing people
get hurt even if it's yet cinematically
done I know it's makeup I know they're
actors but it is based on a very real
thing and it's doing that very real
thing
at some points in film and cinema when
you're illustrating something like this
you have to show the nitty-gritty and
quite frankly my mind set on Peter Berg
as a director is just changing I used to
be like well I'm 50/50 on Peter Berg
movies now it's like 75 25 75 positive
that dude is really crushing it lately
another thing this movie does really
well is it mixes security footage like
as these guys are going about their
business like the bad guys after the
bombing they run across security footage
and it shows the actual security footage
you're like these days you're just doing
some day-to-day how disconnected do
you have to be really murdered some
people then I better go get the milk
like excited negative in this one it's
just the replay value it's such a
heavy-handed movie boot on the ground
your feet are in the mud you're watching
this go down it's interesting it's
fascinating it's taxing on you as you're
watching it you don't have to watch it
over and over and over again in that
there's not a lot of replay value here
there's replay value in this sense that
you watch it and then you get your
friends you like dude you have to watch
this movie I will watch it with you I
guess that's the leg up Deepwater
Horizon has over patriot a Deepwater
Horizon I couldn't watch Deepwater
Horizon a few times in the end guys
Patriots day I was really glad I saw it
was really hard it's a limited release
right now it's gonna go wide in January
but I really wanted to see this one
right now man and it was really well
done it was a heavy movie Mark Wahlberg
was great the characters were great so
great in fact it's weird to call them
characters because they are based on
real people so the people were great and
it does a lot of justice among the
people involved and how the different
agencies work together but kind of had
conflict when they were working together
but they all still had the common goal
to work together and it showed when
tragedy strikes people do innately come
together and I think that's an important
powerful thing and I will say Patriots
day is awesome tacular
alright guys so Patriots day have you
seen it what did you think about it or
what's a great movie that you can only
watch one so that's a good important
question there so whatever you think
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]